medical personnel from the u.s public
health service commission corps arrived
on monday
to provide surge support in indian
country
today we're sending 15 ventilators to
the state and 12 federal medical
personnel will arrive next week to help
get more shots in arms
in wisconsin a 23-person military
medical team is scheduled to start its
support mission
at bellen hospital in green bay on
friday
in new jersey a new federally run free
testing site will open on new year's day
and more sites will open across the next
several days in philadelphia
and washington dc and on top of all of
this a million gloves 342 000 mass
respirators and face shields
and 40 000 gallons
the administration has shipped for
frontline health care workers in states
in the past couple of weeks alone
so as you can see we've been working
around the clock to surge reinforcements
to communities as they battle omicron
helping to staff hospitals administer
monoclonal antibody treatments
transport patients add testing capacity
and get more ppe to where it is needed
and you'll see us continue to act
aggressively to address communities
needs in the days and weeks ahead
so with that let me hand it over to dr
valencia dr malinsky
thank you so much jeff good morning
everyone i'd like to start by walking
you through today's data the current
seven day daily average of cases is
about 240
400 cases per day an increase of about
60
over the previous week
the rapid increase in cases we are
seeing across the country is in large
part a reflection of the exceptionally
transmissible omicron variant
in a few short weeks omicron has rapidly
increased across the country and we
expect will continue to circulate in the
coming weeks
while our cases have substantially
increased from last week
hospitalizations and deaths remain
comparatively low right now
the seven-day average of
hospitalizations
admissions is about 9 000 per day an
increase of about 14 percent over the
previous week this could be due to the
fact that hospitalizations tend to lag
behind cases by about two weeks but may
also be due to early indications that
we've seen from other countries like
south africa and united kingdom
of milder disease from omicron
especially among the vaccinated and the
boosted
and the seven day average of daily
deaths are about eleven hundred per day
which is a decrease of about seven
percent over the previous week
as you continue to watch these trends i
want to emphasize that this virus has
proven its ability to adapt quickly and
we must adapt with it and it is in that
context that last week cdc updated our
isolation and quarantine guidance for
health care workers as we prepare for an
anticipated surge in cover 19 cases
this updated guidance will help to
ensure that hospitals clinics and
long-term care facilities can safely
stay open and remain appropriately
staffed both to handle hospitalizations
from clova 19 and to make sure that we
continue to provide the necessary care
for those experiencing heart attacks
strokes and other illnesses
swiftly thereafter on monday cdc also
updated its recommendations to shorten
the recommended isolation and quarantine
period for the general public
these updates to our recommendations
were made to reflect what we currently
know about copen19 infection including
how long a person is most infectious
studies have demonstrated that when
infection with sarcoma 2 people are
infected with sarcoma 2 people are most
infectious in the one to two days before
symptoms develop and the two to three
days after
after five days the risk of ongoing
transmission substantially decreases
let me make clear that we are standing
on the shoulders of two years of science
two years of understanding
transmissibility and a lot of
information that we have gleaned from
the wild type virus as well as the alpha
and delta variants and more that we
continue to learn every single day about
omicron
we do know the vast majority of viral
transmission happens in those first five
days somewhere in the 85 to 90 percent
range so if a person can isolate for the
first five days they absolutely should
many are asking why do we do not require
a test at the end of the five days of
isolation for those who are infected
we know that pcr testing would not be
helpful in this setting as people can
remain pcr positive for up to 12 weeks
after infection and long after they are
transmissible or infectious
we also don't know that antigen tests
give a good indication of
transmissibility at this stage of
infection
on the other hand we know that after
five days people are much less likely to
transmit the virus and that masking
further reduces that risk and this is
why people need to mask for five days
after their five days of isolation
this science as well as what we know
about the protection provided by masking
vaccination and booster doses and about
our test performance were all part of
what informed our updated
recommendations
let me walk you through exactly what
these new recommendations mean for you
first isolation refers to what you do
when you have coca-19 most likely
diagnosed by a positive test
isolation prevents those who are known
to be infected from transmission
transmitting the virus to others
quarantine on the other hand is
different this is what you do when you
have to be when you've been exposed to
someone who has disease and are unsure
if you yourself were infected
quarantine prevents further spread of
the virus in the time before someone may
develop symptoms or from those who are
asymptomatic from their infection
if you are infected with sars kovi 2
regardless of your vaccination status
you should isolate for five days
during periods of isolation it's best
for you to wear a mask around those in
your household to avoid spreading the
virus at home
after five days if you're asymptomatic
or if your symptoms have largely
resolved
you may leave isolation as long as you
continue to wear a mask around of others
even in the home for an additional five
days
for those who've been exposed to cover
19 quarantine recommendations are based
on your vaccination status
if you are boosted or have been
vaccinated with your pfizer or modernist
series in the past six months or your j
j shot in the past two months
no quarantine is needed however a mask
must be worn for 10 days following your
known exposure and we also recommend
getting a test on day five after your
exposure
if you're not vaccinated or you are
vaccinated with your pfizer or modernist
series over six months ago or with j and
j over two months ago and have not yet
received your booster
you should quarantine for five days
following your last exposure
after five days you should continue
masking around others for an additional
five days and you should also get a test
at day five
if it's not possible for you to
quarantine it is really important that
you do the right thing and wear a mask
at all times around others for 10 days
after your exposure
here we also emphasize that you should
get a test at day five
and if at any point you develop symptoms
of covid19 during your quarantine period
or your 10 days after exposure
like fevers runny nose a cough headaches
or body aches you should get a test and
isolate until your test results return
and of course
then isolate if your test returns
positive
now with these updates to our isolation
and quarantine recommendations i want to
emphasize the critical importance of
masking which we know decreases the risk
of transmission as well as the
importance of staying home when you're
sick if you're sick or have symptoms it
is best for you to stay home and to stay
away from others
as we continue to fight covet 19
prevention is truly our best option
this means for everyone five and older
getting vaccinated and for those
eligible it means getting your booster
shot for everyone it means continuing to
follow our multi-layer prevention
measures including masking in public
indoor settings in areas of substantial
or high community transmission
washing your hands frequently
and testing before gathering when
possible
how well each of these prevention
measures is implemented as well as
adherence to isolation and quarantine
recommendations will determine the
outlook in the coming weeks and months
we at cdc are working to provide updated
recommendations using science to ease
the burden of lengthy isolation and
quarantine recommendations however these
recommendations will only work if people
follow them
as we look to the new year i am hopeful
that we can come together and do what is
in the best interest of our loved ones
our friends and our communities so with
that i say thank you happy new year and
i will now turn things over to dr falchi
thank you very much dr bolinsky i'm
going to concentrate my remarks
predominantly on
severity or not of this disease but
before i do i just want to underscore
something that we always talk about when
we talk about severity
and that is the issue of
transmissibility and immune evasion so
very briefly
we know now incontrovertibly that this
is a highly highly transmissible virus
we know that from the numbers we're
seeing
but i think each individual person
throughout this country is now seeing
around them the high degree of
transmissibility
with regard to immune evasion
very clearly now we have a number of
tests looking at
the effect of omicron on the evasion of
immunity from monoclonal antibodies as
well as from vaccine-induced antibodies
and clearly there is a degree of immune
evasion particularly against infection
and to some degree
against hospitalization however
importantly and the bottom line message
here
is that boosters bring back up that
degree of protection
to a level that is approximating what it
was
before
so boosters are critical
in getting our approach to omicron to be
optimal now let's focus on the severity
of disease i'm going to review some
preliminary observational clinical data
as well as some selected initial
laboratory data
first
the data from south africa
there have been a number of reports
i'll report here
one published yesterday from a large
hospital in the shwanee south african
district
added to an earlier report
that is very similar
covert 19 hospital admissions from the
omicron wave were compared to admissions
from previous waves
and here is the comparison
in hospital deaths
4.5 versus 21.3
icu admissions
one percent from omicron
4.3 for others
45 of patients required supplemental
oxygen with omicron
compared to 99
in a prior wave
length of study four day length of stay
excuse me
four days for omicron
8.8 days for the second wave
mean average age 39 years for omicron
49 years for previous waves
the authors note in that study
that the changing clinical presentation
of sars kobe 2
is likely due to the predominantly high
level of prior infection and to some
extent
vaccination coverage
since vaccine level is relatively low
in the republic of south africa
moving on to the united kingdom
in a study of the uk health security
agency technical briefing
preliminary analysis was looked at from
days november the 22nd
through december the 19th
the risk of presentation to emergency
care
or hospital admissions with omicron
was 60
that of delta
the risk of hospitalization admission
alone with omicron
was 40
of that for delta
these data were fortified by data from
scottish researchers
that showed when analyzed data in the
scottish population from november 1 to
december 19th
preliminary data suggests that omicron
is associated with a two-thirds
reduction
in the risk of covert 19 hospitalization
another study from the uk imperial
college uk report
in the hospitalization risk
analysis of both clinical and laboratory
data
indicate an overall significant
reduction in the risk of hospitalization
for omicron compared to delta
in the united states we are getting
accumulation of data
the spice in cases
is out of proportion
to the increase in hospitalization
so if one looks at 14 day averages the
data as of last night
indicate a plus
126 increase
in cases
and an 11 increase in hospitalizations
now we must remember
that hospitalizations and deaths
are lagging indicators however
the pattern and disparity
between cases and hospitalizations
strongly suggest
that there will be a lower
hospitalization to case ratio
when the situation becomes more clear
just a word about children certainly
more children are being infected with
the highly transmissible virus and with
that
there naturally will be more
hospitalizations in children it is
noteworthy however that many children
are hospitalized with covid
as opposed to because of covid
reflecting the high degree of penetrance
of infection
among the pediatric population
the final conclusion about the level of
severity in children remains to be
determined
and finally some in vitro and animal
data
which address the issue of whether or
not there is inherent lowering of
virulence of the virus
in a study from hong kong
it was shown that although omicron
replicates faster than delta in the
bronchus
there's less efficient replication in
the lung
hamster models from the university of
tokyo
show that omicron poorly infects and
spreads in the lung
and is less pathogenic compared to delta
and a hamster model
belgian researchers in syrian hamsters
see the same thing
nih-funded studies that are ongoing
right now in both mouse and hamsters
confirm
the lesser virulence in the animal model
and studies here at the vaccine research
center that nih in the non-human primate
model are ongoing and will await results
of that
so in conclusion
the data are encouraging
but in still in many respects
preliminary
yet they are getting stronger and
stronger as additional data are
accumulated
and it is still unclear
how these data will translate to other
demographically diverse populations in
the united states and elsewhere
throughout the world but having said
this
all indications point to a lesser
severity of omicron versus delta
it is difficult to determine what degree
of lessened severity
is due to pre-existing immunity
or the intrinsically lower virulence of
omicron as suggested by the animal
studies
or a combination of both
increased transmissibility of omicron
resulting in an extremely high volume of
cases
may override
some of the impact of the lower disease
severity
and so we should not become complacent
since our hospital system could still be
stressed in certain areas of the country
and so to repeat what we say so often
and deserves re-emphasis
the risk of severe disease from any
circulating variant including omicron
is much much higher for the unvaccinated
and so adults and children who are
eligible
get vaccinated
and vaccinated people
get boosted when eligible
back to you jeff
okay well thank you doctors and let's uh
open it up for some questions over to
you kevin
thanks jeff and uh let's try to be as
efficient as possible so we can get
through uh as many questions as people
have first let's go to ricardo at the ap
ricardo
okay can you hear me now now we can yes
thank you okay sorry about that was a
little slow there
um yes i'd like to ask dr walensky
um
what share of the
uh infections that we're seeing now are
accounted for
by
people uh our breakthrough infections
basically so what proportion of the
cases we're seeing now are breakthroughs
same for hospitalizations what
proportion
are breakthroughs and for dr fauci do
you think
that we're going to need
a
a fourth shot another shot just to keep
um
something like omicron or whatever might
be coming next at bay
okay so dr olynyk and then dr belgium
yeah thank you ricardo for that question
what i can tell you is that
compared to people who are
un
to who are boosted if you are
unvaccinated you are 10 times more
likely to be a case and 20 times more
likely to be a fatality
compared to people who are unvaccinated
york 17 times more likely to be in the
hospital so our vaccines are working
really well to prevent severe disease
and hospitalization and death they're
actually also working quite well to
prevent cases all we although we do know
more breakthrough cases are happening in
the context of omicron
dr falchi
yes thank you for that question ricardo
before we start talking about a fourth
shot it would be very important for us
to determine the durability of
protection
particularly against severe disease
for the third shot booster of an mrna
and the second shot of a j j
right now we don't have that information
it is conceivable that in the future we
might need an additional shot but right
now we are hoping that we will get a
greater degree of durability or
protection from that booster shot so
we're going to take one step at a time
get the data from the third boost and
then make decisions based on the
scientific data
next question
go to lori garrett
yes my question is to jeff
over the last
year and a half roughly we've seen a
steady escalation in attacks directed
personally against dr fauci and
generally against public health
leadership including death threats and
this has escalated to the point where we
now have actually had uh jesse waters
call upon his followers in fox news land
to quote ambush tony and his family and
to quote take the kill shot
and then this was backed up by steve
bannon we've had laura logan say to her
followers
that tony is joseph mengele and should
be handled accordingly and so on and all
over the country
public health leaders are getting death
threats they're getting threats against
their families and we have not heard a
peep
from the president from the white house
from members of congress on the democrat
side in the defense of these individuals
or nor have we heard anything about the
department of justice issuing
indictments is it now legal to yell on
in public that people should kill and
ambush federal health officials
well we've talked about disinformation
in these types of threats
as being completely and utterly
unacceptable
the president's been very clear
about how much of an impact this type of
misinformation
is having on the country
so all i can say is that dr fauci is an
extraordinary public servant
as are
the whole team of public health care
professionals in the federal government
across state and local governments
they're doing their jobs
and
this type of disinformation and these
types of threats are completely and
utterly unacceptable
next question let's go to sabrina
siddiqui at the wall street journal
yes thank you so much for doing this um
i know that there's going to be a clear
distinction here between people who are
unvaccinated and those who are
vaccinated but when you're looking at
the vaccinated and boosted population is
it still your goal to minimize covet
cases across the country
or at this point is it more about
preventing further disruptions and
learning how to live with the virus so
it'd be helpful if you can just kind of
articulate where we are at this stage of
the pandemic with respect to
transmissibility and the expectation
that many more people even those who are
vaccinated and boosted will likely be
infected with omicron
dr fauci you want to go first here
yeah i mean obviously as we get further
and further
uh
in experience with omicron and perhaps
even variants that might come after that
it's very very clear for example with
omicron
if you have a larger number of
infections and as the data that i
presented here indicate
that there is looks like a significant
lessening of severity compared to others
it becomes much more relevant
as to what the seriousness of the impact
on society is
we're never going to stop counting tests
but we're
looking
forward as i think everyone feels is
appropriate
that ultimately when we're going to have
to quote live with something that will
not be eradicated and very likely would
not be eliminated
but can actually be at such a lower
level of control
namely a control that does not disrupt
society does not disrupt the economy
that it will be much more relevant
as to what the level of seriousness of
impact is
as opposed to infection which might turn
out to be milder so we very well may see
a transition in that direction as the
months go by
next question
let's go to cheyenne haslett at abc news
hi thank you for taking my question um
can you guys hear me all right yes
okay great i wonder um the fda put out a
confusing statement about rapid tests
last night and i was hoping to get some
clarity
the statement said they're less
sensitive detecting omicron but they
still work can you clarify at exactly
what phase people can actually
trust rapid tests when they should be
using them and can you give it an
accurate number
uh or can you give a number for how
accurate they are up against omicron and
and lastly jeff if you have new numbers
on what percentage of eligible people
are boosted i think you gave some about
two weeks ago that would be helpful
thank you
good so i'll go uh first on the
fda
test and dr fauci if you want to add
anything you know the fda
clearly recommends the use of authorized
at-home tests they are a critical tool
in our efforts to stop the spread of
covenant 19 as
dr malinsky expanded on
earlier with her guidance and
yesterday's release from the fda was to
keep the public aware of their ongoing
work to evaluate
the fda authorized test level of
sensitivity
specifically to omicron
um but it's clear that they are
recommending their continued use
uh as been has been known for a while
and was stated in their release pcr
tests are more sensitive than antigen
tests
but i want to again emphasize that both
are critical tools to stop the spread of
covet 19.
dr palchi anything to or dr winsky
anything to our subtraction well
i think you said it very well uh
jeff when you're dealing with an antigen
test everyone knows from the beginning
that it is not by the nature of the
technical aspect of the test as
sensitive as a pcr so it isn't a hundred
percent sensitive and not like a pcr but
it has a considerable degree of
usefulness
in a number of different circumstances
some of which dr walensky has already
mentioned in her remarks
what the fda was saying that when they
were looking at
the sensitivity with regard to omicron
in some of the tests there appears to be
somewhat of a diminution not a
disappearance but a diminution
of the sensitivity
the fact that the sensitivity is
diminished somewhat does not obviate the
importance of the still advantage and
usefulness
of these tests on the different
circumstances that was the message of
the fda they wanted to make sure they
were totally transparent
in saying the sensitivity might come
down a bit but they did emphasize there
still is an important use of these tests
and jeff if i might add to that another
important use is where we use them for
serial testing in places like test to
stay to keep children in school in
higher ed um to keep our uh
college uh campuses safe so lots of uh
important uses in addition to the one i
outlined and if you're using them
serially um you are able to easily
give up a little bit in terms of
sensitivity
on your question on boosting i think
importantly uh
we're continuing to boost
about a million people a day uh which is
uh a good pace obviously the more people
who get boosted the more people who get
the highest level of protection
uh the data i do have off the top of my
head is we're nearing two out of three
seniors those 65 and older who those who
are most vulnerable of the eligible
seniors about
uh two out of three are now
boosted and i'll follow up or kevin will
follow up and get you the overall
percent of those eligible what percent
have now received
all right next question
let's go to joe lochenbach at washington
post
joel
kevin we're not getting anything on this
end
yes let's uh let's go ahead and
go to jeremy diamond cnn
hey there thanks for uh doing this
briefing um
on the 500 million test can you outline
specific progress that you've made in
getting those 500 million antigen tests
rolled out next month do you have a
launch date for the website and for the
arrival of those first shipments and is
there anything that you're doing to ramp
up pcr capacity uh as well and then
secondly to dr walensky on the
quarantine guidance you know this is the
first time that we've seen you
distinguish between people who are
unvaccinated and those who are fully
vaccinated eligible for a booster but
have not gotten it yet so should those
people who are more than six months from
their second mrna dose or two months
from j j no longer consider themselves
to be fully vaccinated thanks
so on
testing
and the
half billion tests bought by the us
government to be distributed for free
the department of defense and hhs are
executing on an accelerated contracting
timeline companies are
already submitting information and we
expect the contract to be completed
late next week that means that the first
deliveries from manufacturers will start
january
we'll set up a free and easy system
including a new website to get these
tests out to americans
we're actively working to finalize that
distribution mechanism which includes a
website where people will be able to
order tests for free
and we'll share more details in the
weeks
ahead days and weeks ahead
we're able to do this now because of all
the steps we've taken to increase uh
testing supply and manufacturing
capacity we have also taken steps on the
pcr front uh to answer your question
there
you know there are tests available
at many websites and local pharmacies
obviously demand is
stronger in certain areas
even higher and in those areas we're
supplementing as you know with federally
run testing sites that we've set up in
new york city
as i mentioned we're doing the same in
philadelphia new jersey and washington
dc and we're continuing to work with
states to add those federally run
testing sites uh where needed but tests
are available
online and in many local pharmacies the
rapid home test
uh over to you dr wolinski yeah thank
you jeff and thank you jeremy for that
question so our cdc guidance um has been
very clear that people should get their
boost when they are eligible that is
both for because of waning immunity and
because we need more protection against
omicron with regard to your question
specifically about people who have
received two doses of their mrna or
perhaps just one dose of a j and j
vaccine who are eligible for a boost but
haven't yet gotten it we do know that
they do have some protection about
against severe disease and death but um
that they do have quite a bit of waning
with regard to protection against
infection and since these are guidelines
for quarantine we really wanted to have
those
measures in place since they have had
quite a bit of waning protection against
infection
next question
all right we have time for a few more
questions let's uh go to asthma khalid
at npr
hi there thank you guys for doing this
um two quick questions um dr couttry i
know that you have said that you don't
think people should expect any
requirement in domestic flight travels
any domestic travel mandate um there
have been and sure as you all know a
number of public health experts who have
been suggesting that would be a good
move so could you explain the science in
saying you do not think that should be
on the table anytime soon and then for
dr bolensky i know you were on cnn this
morning um speaking to sort of risk
tolerance around the changing quarantine
guidelines and the idea that
behaviorally also folks were not
necessarily going to be
under mild
mild symptoms i'm sorry willing to
quarantine for up to 10 days can you
expound on that for me a little bit um
you know i know that there's been some
pushback from from people thinking that
there are other
um guidelines that have been difficult
for people to tolerate um you know kind
of case in point as the mother of a
toddler keeping a mask on a toddler is
one that i think many parents of young
children say is very difficult from a
behavioral science perspective as well
so um with regard to the the issue of
traveling let me make sure we we
continue to clarify what i've been
trying to do
uh i had said and i and i'll i'll say it
again
that we uh when we talk about keeping
america safe and keeping our citizens
safe everything that is an intervention
is always on the table and always
discussed
and we discuss it regularly on a
literally on a daily and a weekly basis
the difference between requiring uh
vaccination before you get on a plane to
come from out of the country
into the united states is for the
obvious reason of keeping infection
particularly new variants
out of the country
when you're dealing with domestic
flights you want to keep people
safe on domestic flights and as i said
right now we feel that the masking
requirement
and the degree of filtration
on a plane
is sufficient to keep
people safe however as is very clearly
the case for domestic travelers as i
mentioned we want to keep them safe but
we believe that the requirement
achieves that goal if there's a need to
do more
beyond this masking namely
having a vaccine issue
we will seriously consider that as new
information arises so it's just keeping
an open mind
that the situation may change but at
this particular time
we do not feel that it's necessary to
make that a requirement for domestic
flights
yeah thank you jeff um asthma thanks for
this question i think you're referring
to um my discussion with regard to
isolation rather than quarantine and
what we really do know is that the vast
majority of your transmissible time is
in those first five days up to 85 90 of
all of your transmission is happening in
those first five days those two days
before you have symptoms in the two to
three days after so we think it's most
important to make sure that people are
isolating during that period of time and
then any of that lingering small amount
of transmission afterwards would be
prevented by masking
just one follow-up from a previous
question on boosters i did track down
the data
so as i said nearly two out of three
eligible seniors those ages 65 and older
have now been boosted and for 18 and
over so the population 18 and over 45
about 45
uh have now received a boost
of the eligible
but you know those numbers have gone up
a lot uh doing about a million a day but
as the doctors continually emphasize
everybody who's eligible should go get
boosted as soon as possible
next question
all right we're gonna do two more
questions uh nate wexel the hill
thanks uh just a question on the
isolation quarantine guidance uh
why was there no distinction between
vaccinated and unvaccinated with regards
to the five days i mean is there
evidence that
the the virus is is
going to be
less contagious after five days no
matter what your vaccination status is
yeah thank you for
sorry thank you for that question mate
um
the
you know obviously vaccination and
boosting is going to prevent you from
getting virus to begin with but if you
happen to be one of those breakthrough
infections we have seen data that you at
least for other variants that you peak
at around the same place if you happen
to be a breakthrough than you were then
you would if you were unvaccinated you
may have a slightly steeper rate of
decline than if you were unvaccinated
but in fact
most of that is still happening in the
first five days and therefore we didn't
feel like we had enough granularity to
distinguish between the two
next question
last question let's go to evan lambert
at news nation now
thanks for taking my questions i have
two uh so i'm still a little bit unclear
on why the isolation guidelines don't
include suggesting a negative antigen
test if people can get one why shouldn't
they check to make sure they aren't
infectious before they leave isolation
and then the second one i guess maybe
for dr fauci can we get a clear
recommendation should americans cancel
their new year's eve plans thank you
dr wolinski
yeah so um
the
we do know that certainly a pcr you can
stay positive in your pcr for a long
period of time but with regard to the
question of your antigen is we do not
know how well those antigen tests
perform at day five in detecting
transmissibility
and it is for that reason that we would
say even if you had a negative test we
would want you to mask and even if you
had a positive test we would also want
you to mask and therefore given that the
these these antigen tests are not
authorized for use in this way we did
not recommend them at that time
dr faucini is youth
uh yes uh thank you very much for that
question
so similar to what i said uh for the
christmas holiday
it goes true here if you are in a
situation with a family setting
in your home
with family
parents children grandparents
and everyone is vaccinated
and boosted
although the risk is never zero in
anything the risk is low enough that we
feel you should continue to go through
with those plans of having a home
related
vaccinated boosted gathering
with family and close friends who are
also vaccinated and boosted
so it really depends
on what your plans are you said should
you change or cancel your plans
if your plans are to go to a 40 to 50
person
new year's eve party with all the bells
and whistles and everybody hugging and
kissing and wishing each other a happy
new year i would strongly recommend that
this year we do not do that
thank you everybody
thanks for joining i wish everybody
a safe and happy new year and we'll look
forward to next week's return to our
normal style briefings thank you
you